hier ces personnes toutes Gries c'était
sombre c'était gris ça sentait beaucoup
la chemin mais ça avait pas l'air d'être
un couple d'urgence encore
et il y avait comme une pluie c'était
spécial ben ça ressemble à un début
d'apocalypse pour ouvrir un peu comme ce
qu'on voit dans les films de
catastrophe naturelle c'était Somme puis
tu sentais qu'il y avait comme une
tension là donc la panique a pris le
plus je vous montrerai pas que au moment
où est-ce que les amis m'ont appelé
m'ont dit ok garde on s'en vient de
chercher c'est pas tout seul et puis
c'est sur la première personne que j'ai
contacté c'est vraiment mon ex-conjoint
pour m'assurer que mes enceintes en
sécurité puis qu'il y a l'exciter la
ville sous peu donc j'ai ramassé tout ce
qui était le chargeur de téléphone j'ai
validé que j'avais de l'argent sur moi
que j'avais mes cartes
j'ai fermé tous les lumières tous les
appareils qui vont être fonctionnels à
la maison qui était
inutile
la première heure qu'on était en route
avec la conductrice qui était là avec
moi ouais on a paniqué les mains et moi
peut-être stresser l'adrénaline dans le
tapis on savait pas trop on essaie de
communiquer avec les gens mais en même
temps on veut garder le cap sur la route
les gens chauffaient très mal je sais
pas vous dire ça faisait longtemps sur
la route ça a dépassé c'était n'importe
quoi les enfants sont pas fous là ils
sentaient ce qui se passait ils
sentaient le vendre panique donc moi mes
enfants n'étaient pas au courant qu'on
fuyait à cause des feux de forêt par
contre les enfants avec qui j'étais à
les 6 autres enfants le SAV donc il y
avait un vent de panique vraiment il y
en a plusieurs autour de moi justement
que hier c'était les larmes laisser leur
chance derrière là il y avait fort qu'on
ferme nos maisons leurs objets de valeur
donc c'est sûr que dans l'attaque d'un
enfant c'est une catastrophe phénoménale
on sait pas ce qui va arriver donc notre
travail de maman a été très ardu pendant
les premières heures de voyage
de voir la solidarité qui a quand même
parce qu'on n'est pas habitué à ça de
400 comme ça au Québec donc c'est les
gens sont très chaleureux sont très
accueillants il y a beaucoup beaucoup
d'entraxes c'est vraiment beau à voir
pour vrai on est vraiment soigné d'avoir
tout ce support là autour de nous